Hi, I’m Adriene Hill, and Welcome back to
Crash Course, Statistics.
We’ve been talking a lot about how to tell
whether two groups are different like whether
there’s more car accidents on rainy days
than snowy days.
or whether the IQ of university students is
actually different from the population.
Today, we’re going to start a conversation
about statistical inference, which tells us
how we can go from describing data we already have to making inferences about data we don’t have.
INTRO
If you’ve watched any of the other videos
in this series, you’ve heard a lot about
uncertainty.
It comes up endlessly in statistics.
And uncertainty is at the core of what Inferential
Statistics is about: making decisions about
ideas, or hypotheses.
I might be interested in whether listening
to Mozart while doing calculus homework improves
my calculus grades.
But I need to test my hypothesis, I can’t
just have an idea and claim it’s correct
without any evidence.
One thing we need for sure, is data.
So we could randomly sample two groups of
25 people and make half of them listen to
Mozart and half to do their homework in silence.
We collect their calculus grades and see that
those who listened to Mozart scored on average
3 points higher than those who didn’t.
So Mozart’s good.
Problem solved, break out Sonatas, right?
Unfortunately, no.
We’ve seen that sample parameters like the
mean are just estimates of the mean of the
population that they are taken from.
The sample mean score of the Mozart group
is higher.
But we don’t have sufficient evidence that
the population mean of Mozart listeners is
higher than those who did their work in silence.
We may have gotten an especially high sample mean that isn’t close to the true population mean.
So we need a way to test our hypothesis while
taking into account the random variation of
sample means.
In theory, one way you could test a hypothesis
or model is by how well it predicts the data
you got.
For example, you and your best friend really
love giraffes, and you’ve spent a lot of
time watching them at the zoo and drawing
sketches of them.
So you both have a hypothesis about the average
number of spots a baby giraffe has, but they’re
slightly different.
You think that baby giraffes have an average
of 175 spots, with a standard deviation of
50 spots, and your best friend thinks that
baby giraffes have an average of 209 spots
with a standard deviation of 45 spots.
With the permission of your local zoo, of
course, you begin to collect a random sample
of baby giraffes and count how many spots
they had.
Your sample of 25 baby giraffes had a mean
of 200 spots.
Now that you have data, you can use it to
evaluate which one of you is more likely to
be right.
Both you and your friend have a model or idea
about what the population distribution of
baby giraffe spots is.
If you’re right, then the sampling distribution
of all the possible sample means we could
get looks like this: (RED in chart)
And the distribution of sample means for your friend’s model looks like this: (black in chart)
Let’s look at where our sample mean of 200
lies on both of these distributions.
You can see that you’re more likely to see
a mean of 200 spots under your friend’s
hypothesis than yours.
If your model were correct, a mean of 200
spots is pretty rare...it’s in the top 1.2%
most extreme values we’d expect to see,
whereas in your friend’s model, a mean of
200 spots is only in the top 32%, which means
it’s pretty common that we’d see sample
means around 200 if your friend’s model
was correct.
But we don’t always have predictions that
are as specific as you and your friend’s
predictions about baby giraffe spots.
We might have a more general hypothesis, like
that the average number of baby giraffe spots
is more than 200... but that’s all that
you really know.
In situations like these, one common method of testing ideas is Null Hypothesis Significance Testing (NHST)
You have a hypothesis.
That people with a certain gene, we’ll call
it gene X, eat a different amount of calories
than the general population.
Null Hypothesis Significance testing asks
you to test a different hypothesis--which
says there is no difference or effect of this
gene.
And we’ll see how well this null hypothesis
predicts the data we’ve collected.
In this case the null hypothesis--or null
model-- is that the population mean caloric
intake for people with gene X is actually
2,300, the same as the regular population.
If the null hypothesis is found to be infeasible,
we can “reject” it.
We can represent this hypothesis like this:
This might seem like a pretty round about
way to test your theory that people with gene
X eat differently, and that’s because it
is.
Null Hypothesis Significance testing is a
form of the reductio ad absurdum argument
which tries to discredit an idea by assuming
the idea is true, and then showing that if
you make that assumption, something contradictory
happens.
For example, you can use reductio ad absurdum
to show that there is no largest positive
integer.
Let’s assume there is a largest positive
We’ll call it AB for “absurdly big”.
Now add one to AB.
shoot.
That would be a larger positive integer...which
would be absurd since AB is the largest.
Therefore, by reductio ad absurdum, there
is no largest positive integer.
By the way, if this kind of argument sounds
familiar, it might because reductio ad absurdum
is like proof by contradiction.
Let’s test the null hypothesis for our our
gene X case.
First, we assume that the mean number of calories
eaten by people with gene X is 2,300, just
like the regular population.
If we can show that this assumption makes
something “absurd” happen, then we can
“reject” the idea that it’s true.
With data from 60 people with gene X, we see
that the mean number of calories eaten was
2,400 with a sample standard deviation of
500 calories.
We have to ask how rare or “absurd” it
would be to get a sample mean that is this
far away from our assumed mean of 2,300.
Essentially, we imagine that we take a random
sample of 60 people with gene X over and over
and over again and calculate the mean.
Then we ask how many times out of all those
experiments, do we get a sample mean that’s
as far away from 2,300 as our actual sample
mean of 2,400 is.
Even if you haven’t heard of the term null
hypothesis significance testing, you may have
heard of p-values which have been covered
everywhere from academic journals, to Buzzfeed
articles.
A p-value answers the question of how “rare”
your data is by telling you the probability
of getting data that’s as extreme as the
data you observed if the null hypothesis was
true.
If your p-value was 0.10 you could say that
your sample is in the top 10% most extreme
samples we’d expect to see based on the
distribution of sample means.
If we assume that the null hypothesis is true,
and the mean caloric intake of people with
gene X is 2,300 with a standard deviation
of 500 calories, the distribution of sample
means will look like this, and tells us which
means we expect to see and how often we expect
to see each of them.
Sample means around 2,300 are most common,
but we’ll also often see sample means a
little bit further away.
We can use this distribution to calculate
our p-value.
This is similar to how we compared the likelihood
of 200 giraffe spots in you and your friend’s
models, but with only 1 model this time.
Here’s our sample mean of 2,400 on this
graph.
Only about 8.99 percent of the possible sample
means are higher than 2,400.
So it’s not that unlikely that we’d get
a sample mean that’s this high if the true
population mean was 2,300 calories.This is
called a one-sided p-value since it only tells
us the probability of getting a sample mean
that’s higher than 2,400.
Often when we ask scientific questions like
“Does this medicine have a different level
of efficacy than the existing treatment?”
we don’t know which direction the effect
will be in.
The new medicine might be better...or it might
be worse.
Gene X’ers might eat more, or they might
eat less.
Because of this--and a few other reasons we’ll
talk about later in the series--p-values are
often two-sided, meaning that we look at how
far away a value is from the mean, regardless
of if it’s higher or lower . This allows
us to reject the null hypothesis if our value
is significantly higher than the mean, or
if the value is significantly lower than the
mean.
Because the distribution of sample means is
symmetrical, if 9% of the samples of caloric
intake are higher than a mean of 2,400, about
18 percent of sample means for calories would
be as far away or further from the population
mean than 2,400 is in either direction.
In other words, a two-sided p-value is a measure
of how extreme your sample mean is, because
it tells you how often you’ll get a value
that’s as or more extreme than the one you
got.
The smaller your p-value is, the more “rare”
it would be to get your sample just by random
chance alone if the null is true.
In our example, we learned that if we assume
that there is no effect of gene X on caloric
intake, then there would be an 18% chance,
about 1 in 5, that we’d see a sample like
this just because of the random variation
of samples.
To finish our attempt at reductio ad absurdum,
we have to decide whether this sample is “absurd”
or “extreme” enough to lead us to believe
that this sample probably isn’t from the
null distribution.
But that decision isn’t always an easy one
to make...It’s not clear how “rare”
or “absurd” a sample needs to be before
I decide to “reject” the idea that the
sample was taken from a population that has
the null distribution.
Especially since we don’t have another distribution
to compare it to, like we did with the giraffes.
Our p-value of 0.18 tells us that if we took
a sample like this over and over, about 1
out of every 5 times we’d get a sample with
a mean caloric intake that’s further from
the mean than 2,400 calories is.
1 in 5’s not bad...but a 1 in 20 chance
might be better.
And 1 in 100 better than that.
Some statisticians see a p-value as a continuous
measure of evidence.
A p-value of 0.18 like ours might be considered
pretty weak evidence that our sample isn’t
taken from the null distribution.
But it’s better than 0.19, which is in turn
better than 0.20 and so on.
However, in Null Hypothesis Significance Testing,
p-values need a cutoff.
We could set a cut of at 0.05 and say that
a p-value that is less than 0.05 is sufficient
evidence to allow us to “reject” the idea
that the null hypothesis is true.
When we can reject the null hypothesis, we
consider our result to be “statistically
significant”, which is basically a phrase
that just means “unlikely due to random
chance alone”.
As we’ll see later on, it doesn’t always
mean that it should be “significant” or
meaningful to you.
A cutoff of 0.05 means that we want our sample
value to be at least in the top 5% of most
extreme values in our distribution before
we consider the value evidence against that
hypothesis.
And any p-value less than the 0.05 cutoff
counts.
0.049 leads to the same conclusion as 0.0001.
Both cause you to reject the null hypothesis.
The current scientific consensus in most fields
is that your cutoff--or alpha--should be 0.05.
But there’s huge disagreement in the field
of statistics about whether 0.05 is appropriate,
and we’re going to dive into later.
In the meantime I’m going to get 24 more
giraffes so I can compare my model with my
friends.
Thanks for watching.
I’ll see you next time.